all right new rule the Korean craves
mukbang or a broadcast eating where fans
watch internet celebrities binge eating
huge meals has to come to America
because I think we can beat them at this
after all what Koreans call binge eating
we call eating here well somebody needs
to tell the autocorrect in my phone that
I often do use the word either and don't
want to change it to wither in fact the
only time I want to type the word wither
is to write I hope the guy who invented
autocorrect lived to see his balls with
her and whole new role racists can't
complain that white people aren't
reproducing enough until white hipsters
get rid of the man bun you want to know
why anglo-saxons are unpro creating meat
patient zero
new rule now that BMW CEO Harold Kruger
has fainted while introducing their new
line of car is at a Frankfurt Auto Show
I've got to try me some of those cars
they made a German guy faint I didn't
even know they could feel either these
BMWs are incredible or someone just told
this guy his daughter was marrying a
Syrian refugee
they're real men who by dr. nipple the
the pasties were men designed to keep
their nipples from showing through their
shirt have to admit they just like
sticking things on their nipple died
because is this really a problem in my
entire life as a man with nipples I've
never once had to say hey my eyes are up
here
you